each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
and now I'd like to introduce to you dr.
George Dennis's
thank you very much DC thanks everybody
for coming today JC kindly invited me
here by telling me that I should give a
talk that is inspiring and I guess that
is the most scary request I've ever had
since for many years now I have been
involved on the very technical side on
working and privacy technology so my
attempt today is to keep this talk very
high level and I don't assume that
everybody here has a security or privacy
background so is there any questions do
let me know immediately to clarify
matters so I'm going to also leave
enough time at the end of this talk to
have a discussion about all these issues
and here probably other views on on the
topics i'm going to introduce but the
key thing i'm going to be talking about
today is privacy but from a very
specific perspective i'm going to be
talking about privacy which we often
encounter as a very general property
without a very clear definition from the
point of view of traditional computer
security okay and furthermore i'm going
to say that it is a very useful
framework to look at it as traditional
security property in order to be able to
reason about privacy how am I going to
do that in two parts first I'm going to
present a framework about privacy to
help us think about it as a security
property and then I'm going to look back
at traditional computer security and see
what does the privacy aspect that I
would have introduced add to a very
traditional view as I said I've tried to
keep all this very high level I'm going
to talk about security policies and
security properties without actually
going to the technical details now of
course it's if some of you are
particularly interested or provoke me to
do that I've spent many years of my life
looking at this I'm happy to actually
engage with that but it's not actually
as useful I'm going to keep also clear
focus on the real world there are lots
of people who think about privacy in
terms of what could be done
in maybe a hundred 150 years in an ideal
society in another world but let's try
to actually look at real problems that
real people today have and real
solutions may be that we may come up
with in the next 5 10 15 years put them
into products and have them on our
desktops so let's first describe a
caricature of the debate about security
and privacy as we very often see it and
I'm saying it's a caricature because I'm
not going to be totally fair so don't
jump on me immediately because I I
accept that this is not actually
completely fair representation but very
often we hear about privacy as being
something very important and now I say
privacy without really defining what I
mean because really when we read in the
newspapers or where we when we see it on
TV as a term it's never really clearly
defined we all have a feel for it but
it's never really clear defined so
privacy is always presented as important
but there are counterweights to it that
are always presented the first
counterweight is that with too much
privacy so if everybody has too much
privacy than you know there would be
abuses and things would be an
accountable actions they're the actions
the private actions would be an
accountable so that's the first problem
the second problem is what about law
enforcement if we have very good privacy
and no one can actually know what their
neighbor is up to then who knows you
know your neighbor might be up to making
drugs and killing people and you never
know okay and law enforcement would
never know so that's that's clearly not
good and then of course you know if we
have systems that make it easy to speak
privately and communicate privately then
we would have massive copyright
infringement and massive libel and
everybody would be saying anything and
everything about everybody else and no
one would be able to hold them
accountable okay and usually along with
this kind of debate we have this kind of
very cliche term that goes a bit like
well if you're a good person and you
have nothing to fear you have nothing to
hide so sure we all may want to go to
the doctor some days and have some kind
of
avid meeting with them to discuss about
our health but fundamentally we don't
have that many secrets okay so as long
as in this small areas of our life we
have some privacy it's going to be okay
now all of this debate leads to some
established wisdom and the established
wisdom usually is that there is a need
for a balance between privacy and
security that we need to control and
limit dangerous technologies such as
encryption and all that stuff that
allows us to have private communications
between us and such things and often
research as well and that has led us to
today in a world where really we have
what often we call in technology policy
circles surveillance by design people
when the design infrastructure or design
products first thing well how we going
to be able to observe everything that is
going on to log everything to make sure
that it can be audited by outsiders by
police by law enforcement by lawyers by
all these people and often at the end of
this process there is really no privacy
left there are often privacy statements
and good feelings but no real privacy
left okay and of course all this debate
leads us to the to the conclusion that
between security and privacy security is
most important okay so I have a lot of
respect for that kind of framework i
present it as i quickly as a caricature
because i want to move beyond it i have
a lot of respect for it but i think it
doesn't give us the intellectual
framework to really think deeply about
privacy and security so let me actually
present a completely alternative
framework an alternative framework that
starts with the brief history of
computer security okay and this brief
history of computer security was
actually outlined first by Roger Needham
who was the head of research microsoft
research in Cambridge and set it up and
I will actually make a point of
highlighting all the people who have
worked on what I'm going to be
mentioning that are from Microsoft so
that in the spirit of the program that
JC is putting forward people know what
their colleagues
working on so Roger Needham presented
computer security as being from having
to ira's the first era of computer
security is the early days and most of
the computer security was concerned with
security properties of the military and
the government it's obvious because they
were the ones who had computers no one
else really had computers before then in
in any serious scale and of course
governments and the military have to
keep secrets so most of the security
properties that they were looking for at
the time was to preserve the secrets ie
confidentiality and lots of very
interesting work was done most of it is
classified sadly but a lot of work was
done how to build secure operating
systems that maintained classification
levels with no information leakage and
all these things and computer security
was one part of maintaining their
secrets and it's important to realize
that along with computer security
governments in the military had an army
had a legal system to actually support
them had very advanced research
facilities the police the Official
Secrets Act and all that's up to keep
their secrets okay so we have this
confidentiality property and we have all
these mechanisms to maintain it that's
the early days then what happened is
that computers became more and more
popular first in enterprises so from the
70s to the 90s there was a clear shift
in focus in computer security towards
ensuring that commercial enterprises
don't have their property is violated
and what was most importantly turns out
was not confidentiality in that context
but integrity when you're a bank okay
and suddenly you don't anymore have
little books with how much money each
person has but you actually transfer all
these books into computer it's really
important that no one can actually
change these numbers okay it's a problem
from the point of view particularly of
customer privacy if one customer can
read the balance of another customer but
actually changing the balances and
transferring money in an uncountable way
is the big problem okay so a lot of the
research in the end of the 70s the 80s
beginning of the night it has really
focused on integrity and authenticity in
that you need to not be able to change
things at random in order to have a
reliable commercial system okay and this
is where Needham's history kind of ended
at the beginning of the 90s but I'm
going to push it one step further
because that is really the interesting
framework in which we can unspent
privacy and I'm going to say that from
the 90s to today we have again a very
different scene out there in computer
security suddenly computers are not just
use banter prizes anymore they're not
just present in bank branches in the
military but they are actually present
in everybody's desktop okay not only
that but in the middle of the 90s the
computers that were on everybody's
desktop since the beginning of the 80s
started actually get networked together
okay they started talking to each other
they started talking with the whole
infrastructure and suddenly everybody
that is not just the government and
enterprise I started having security
concerns okay but unlike the two
previous era the era of the government
properties confidentiality that was
enforced using computer security on one
side but also the Army and the police
and the legal system or the erf
enterprise security where again it was
enforced using computer security tools
but also accountants lawyers a whole
tech department all that stuff these
days the people have this new security
concern the people who have the
computers on their desk or small time
users don't actually have all these
armies of either military or lawyers
tech support people and all that stuff
so they have security properties on one
side that they need to protect but they
don't really have major means as before
in order to protect the security
properties now
let's have a peek at these new kind of
security properties and who are the
people who have them because my main
thesis here is that privacy as this kind
of cloud that is often not very well
defined is better understood as the
collection of security properties of
this third category of people the people
who just have desktop computers and have
to interact in a word that is semi
hostile with very limited means okay now
the first thing to to think carefully
about in order to move out of the
caricature that we're usually left with
is that these are valid security
properties okay these people have needs
they very often move in a hostile
environment and they need to protect
somehow themselves and also what they're
trying to do against the hostile
environment okay now privacy in this
sense is not just about protecting
themselves by not giving out information
that is a very basic definition and very
simplistic I think definition of privacy
privacy in that context is about
self-determination in an information
environment it is about these small-time
people these small-time entities okay
being able to kind of project their
dreams and project their interests into
the information environment that is
often hostile and has often other aims
and other dreams from their own okay and
some examples are being free from
surveillance in order to be able to move
around and discover new things a
flexibility to access and use content
and services even if you are behind a
firewall even if there is some kind of
policy that some content might be off
bounds and freedom from compulsion you
do not want under compulsion to be
forced to do things all these properties
are the properties that the small-time
people need and our properties that in
fact privacy technology is addressing
and of course and that is really really
important when we're talking about
privacy technology these are small
entities with no armies no major access
to tech support no major access to
lawyers none of that
now of course I've always talked very
vaguely about small entities but who are
the small entities of course households
and individual citizens are a perfect
example maybe they are they're actually
the most vulnerable they have a computer
and this computer is quite important to
them often they do business they do part
of some business on it they write
letters they have content they use it to
communicate with their friends their
family their relatives in times in any
times but actually they don't have much
tech support they don't have much know
how themselves they're really vulnerable
yet they still have aspirations and
security properties that would try to
protect but no means the second category
say is non-government organization
societies groups groupings of people
again I mean these guys might have some
budget to actually employ someone to set
up a network but very often not to
maintain or anything like that so
they're small entities again they have
very clear particularly non-governmental
organizations that work in hostile
environments they have very clear
security needs very few means to achieve
them okay but if we keep thinking who
are the small entities in terms of the
the means they have to to achieve
self-determination in an information
environment then we start thinking well
what about small companies you know you
have a small company four or five people
shop you still need computers to run
your business to do your accounting and
all that stuff but you don't have a tech
department you don't have anyone to call
to when things go wrong when you have
viruses on your computer or spyware when
things start going wrong so these are
some house or small companies and then
if we continue like that thinking okay
who's the small with no many means
entity we start thinking about smallish
governments okay and there I'm asking
you to stretch a bit your imaginations
because you're going to say well the
reason of government that can't afford
tech support it's obvious but
it's not always as clear and there was
actually an example from a news item
from the Greek news Greece is a member
of the European Union if people don't
know that it's it's not a third-world
country by any definition it's actually
an advanced society and what happened
was that one day the CEO of one of the
mobile companies increase goes to the
Prime Minister and they say well we're
sorry your phones along with phones of
ministers and phones of the army and all
these people Humabon phones were tapped
for the last year we just discovered it
okay now lots of us privacy
professionals and security professionals
thought about this story and we're like
okay you know what kind of technical
know how does the Greek government in a
major government have to actually go and
audit a mobile operator like mobile
equipment is not manufactured design
specified increase its specified
somewhere else in the GSM consortiums in
this case it is manufactured by ericsson
which is not a great company it is
actually deployed in greece by a great
company Vodafone that is actually a
subsidiary of a British company and
really it's private property they don't
have any reason to go in there and start
looking at it there means in this
context are extremely limited they're as
limited as a home users that is plugging
their computer into the internet socket
they don't have any ability to really
influence the infrastructure as much as
the Greek government doesn't really have
the ability to influence the GSM and
mobile phone infrastructure in Greece
okay so a lot of this property start by
being the main concern of very small
entities but then we discovered that
this small entity is far from being the
exception turn out in many cases to be
the rule okay and if we exclude maybe
major governments that have specialized
agencies looking after security or major
companies that have specialized
departments looking at that everybody
else is in a bit of a difficult position
now
why am I saying that privacy is security
okay these concerns this legitimate
concerns that people have about their
safety about the safety of the dreams
they try to project upon the world it's
not just something that can be satisfied
with good intentions good privacy
statements nice PR and all that stuff it
is something that deserves to be
fulfilled as a property in the same way
as we have been fulfilling traditional
security properties like confidentiality
in the time of the military and the
government or integrity in the time of
commercial entities I we need to have
technology that supports securing these
properties we can't just rely on
people's good intentions okay and laws
are necessary in order to support an
environment that allows people to get
this privacy and security properties but
it's not good enough and it's sad but
it's not good enough think about a
bridge in some ways right the fact that
there is a law that says that this
bridge must stand your car going over it
doesn't automatically mean that the
bridge will you still need to have the
concrete and the iron and the design
that will actually sustain your car
someone putting a nice you know
disclaimer saying oh you know what it's
okay we just would just claim that this
bridge does it without using the
concrete and the iron is not going to
convince anyone and of course when it
came to top-secret documents being
protected at the times of military
communication stuff like that it was
ever enough to just put a top secret
label you need to have the fortified
rowers you need to have the encryption
technologies to support these properties
now it isn't always possible to provide
very strong technology sometimes you
need to share your data sometimes your
data will be exposed in this case
instead of thinking about protecting
your data maybe we need to shift our
attention towards auditing and making
sure that the citizens and small
entities general
we are in a position to gain assurance
that nothing bad is happening to them
again this is not just about PR this is
not just about a privacy statement it is
about technology supporting odets
technology supporting them getting the
assurance that nothing bad is going to
happen and the collection of these ideas
and the collection of these technologies
is what we call privacy enhancing
technologies this is a field a subfield
that would say of computer security that
is very much in its infancy the the
first workshop was actually in two
thousand it starts quite far back in the
past in 1980 when David charm first
proposed how to do anonymous
communications it has grown very slowly
and really boomed five years ago with a
lot of new research is looking into it
sadly I would wish to come here and say
well we have all the answers we don't
have all the answers and we'll talk a
bit more when we get more specific about
the answers we have the answers we don't
have but it's it's an active field of
research and it's a worthwhile pursuit
now there is one more twist that is
quite important to realize and this has
been repeated in many debates before the
twist is that we are all all the users
using pretty much the same
infrastructure okay and that includes
government and the military that
includes enterprises and that includes
these days home users and small entities
to now what is this infrastructure I
mean of course there is the obvious
telecommunication infrastructure that's
you know the wires and the routers and
the signalling equipment and the
protocols that run on them but I put as
part of infrastructure you will be
pleased also operating systems the idea
that the military is going to be using
custom built operating systems is not
any more of this world they're going to
use windows they're going to use Linux
they're going to use Solaris they're not
going to make their own it's going to be
too expensive it's going to be outdated
by the time it's shipped and it's going
to be horrendously expensive
okay I also put in the same category as
infrastructure search engines online
shops where do you think that companies
buy their stuff they buy it online like
everybody else particularly small
companies and software generally that
supports this information environment
and the twist is that if you deny some
form of security privacy to some users I
either home users maybe the small
entities because they don't have really
the cloud to push for this properties
being part of the infrastructure then
you're denying it from everybody else
too and this is indeed the classic
example from the Greek wiretap case that
I mentioned before where no one would
really be surprised if small entities
got their phones tapped they rarely have
no means of actually making sure that
the information security is respected
but it was a great surprise when the
Prime Minister himself had his mobile
phone tapped why is that he is using the
same technology Vodafone doesn't yet
know if it is the Prime Minister's phone
and therefore it should be extra extra
secure or my phone they just use the
same infrastructure and those abusing
the infrastructure use the same
techniques very easily to do
surveillance now I hope I'm starting to
convince you that privacy if we see we
can see privacy as a set of security
properties for the small entities and it
is useful to do that because as we say
security is an important thing security
is important and also that privacy is
not just any more about the household
and maybe the citizen it is actually a
concern for many people who don't have
many means to protect themselves now
where to go next is the question what
I'm going to try to do is go through
some very traditional security
properties that we think are very much
set and look at them from the point of
view of privacy and see where they lack
the support that someone who is looking
for privacy needs some of them need to
be augmented some of them are
antithetical to privacy we'll see that
so at the beginning
of any computer security that was
authentication and again this is a Roger
Needham's early work in the 70s worth
about authentication protocol what is
the first thing you do when you walk to
a terminal you type your username and
your password okay that's the first step
to then have any security policy okay
now does it make sense to have
authentication in our current world it's
a it's a good question I mean in the
good old days the military and the
government had a list of all their
soldiers or officers every Enterprise
had the list of employees they were
issued with authentication credentials
you step to a terminal you put in your
username and your password and there is
a policy governing you that's fine these
days you go to an online shop they don't
know who you are they've never heard of
you before maybe they will never hear of
you again what are these credentials why
do we perform a tent occasion to start
with a good question and there are lots
of people who work on this question
exactly which is about identity
management and how to do identity
management in a very contemporary
setting and Kim Cameron actually from
Microsoft is working on this I'm not
going to go too far into this mostly
because maybe Kim is going to listen to
the tape and not be happy so instead of
that i'm going to say how could we
augment maybe authentication to be more
privacy friendly okay and there are two
main subjects that i'm going to touch
very briefly which is private
authentication and anonymous credentials
how does authentication protocols how
does education protocols traditionally
work okay so we have Alice and Bob let's
say I'm Alice what I do is I'm saying
into this crowded room hi I'm Alice you
down there Bob here is some cryptic
credentials to prove that I'm Atlas and
you Bob from down the room you're like
oh hi Alice and Bob yes and here are
some cryptic credentials and we continue
like that and even though the
authentication in theories between Alice
and Bob everybody who's listening knows
that it is actually between
that I am Alice and his Bob and probably
were trying to communicate with each
other how unnecessary okay how different
from the intuition that most people have
about a secure channel which is more
like you know we walk to each other and
in a kind of quite voice say hi you know
I'm George I've heard of you and
continue like that okay how unnecessary
and indeed there is a a new trend in
authentication protocol to move away
from that paradigm and implement what is
called private authentication ok this is
limiting the amount that third parties
can gain from listening into an
authentication protocol but still
gaining the same authentication
assurance between Alice and Bob at the
end this is a real problem right I don't
know if any of you has sat on a in a
cybercafe spoofed basically the Wi-Fi
access and looked at the IM
conversations of other people even if
those were encrypted you would still be
able to get their instant messenger ID
and if you quite like them and maybe you
would quite like to meet them you just
send them a message this is real hassle
that happens in real life and it really
highlights the need for a private mode
of authentication where I listen Bob
authenticated each other no one else
knows about it it's also quite nice to
to see that it's not a very easy
property to gain so there have been many
iterations trying to get this properties
and it's nice to see that because
authentication really is a
thirty-year-old field and everybody
filled well it's done it's all done what
are we looking at and now we have all
this new properties creeping in that add
a new life to it the second form of
authentication that is quite interesting
and very interesting from the point of
view of privacy technologies anonymous
credentials what are anonymous
credentials there are actually really
complex mathematical tools and many
people try to present the mathematical
tools instead of the intuition behind
the intuition is extremely simple you go
to a cinema right you go to the box
office you buy your tickets you hold
your tickets that's fine everybody has
done that then you walk to the door
of the cinema where maybe between that
you buy popcorn or all that stuff but
you walk through the door with your two
tickets you present the tickets to the
person checking tickets at the door and
then they let you get in you have
basically a credential the ticket is a
credential that allows you access to the
cinema okay it's very simple anonymous
credentials are exactly the same thing
instead of walking to the box office and
saying hi I'm Jordan esas could I have a
ticket then they give me a ticket and
then walking through the door and say hi
i'm george the nessus here is my ticket
they realize that it's quite unnecessary
to have a name linking these two and as
long as there is a a credible entity
that says I have the ability to get in
and a credible way that gives us
assurance that this entity says that
statement about me I don't have to say
Who I am and I can just walk straight in
these credential systems are
fantastically powerful they actually
look like magic to me when I started
looking at them now not only you can
have one attribute I I can get in the
cinema out of the cinema but basically
you can have any string as an attribute
you can have basically a virtual let's
say passport you can have an attribute
for your nationality you can have an
attribute for your date of birth you can
have attributes for all of that so if
you walk to a bar how many times people
have been asked for ID and show the fool
ID with your name and everything instead
of showing your fool idea you can just
say oh I can prove to you that I'm older
than 18 or 21 i think it is here and get
a beer I don't need to actually show you
my name right and you can do that not
only you can prove arbitrary statements
boolean statements such as I am older
than 18 or 21 and i'm a member of your
video rental car club but you can also
have range statements such as i'm born
between that time and that time i'm
allowed to take tapes between that time
and that time without actually giving
any more information okay now there is a
downside credentials are also important
because if you have double spending
controls I if you show your credentials
twice you actually get caught and D
anonymized then you can have digital
cash and this is how digital cash works
that's just a technical side issue to
see how these things are all linked with
each other anonymous coins and
credentials now the downside is that the
cryptography necessary is quite heavy
which makes it difficult to actually
implement in a small smart card yet
smart cars are getting bigger and the
second downside is a policy downside
which is that the credential technology
being very advanced is actually patented
so maybe for the next 15 or I don't know
how many years is going to be very
difficult to use it freely as part of
the infrastructure because of that
unless there is some kind of agreement
so let's leave authentication to to that
but I hope I have convinced you that for
something as traditional as
authentication when we actually start
looking at privacy properties and what
little people who might be very
vulnerable even if their name is known
care about then we can actually start
putting new life into this traditional
security but what I'm going to look next
is the second most traditional security
mechanism which is the secure channel
okay and the secure channel is really
the basis of most of the deployed
security out there we have PGP s/mime
SSL ssh IPSec which basically establish
a secure channel between Alice and Bob
usually with some part of an indication
what are the properties of the secure
Channel traditionally the property is
first authenticity I want to make sure
I'm talking to Bob and Bob wants to make
sure that he's talking to me the second
property of course is confidentiality no
third party should be able to look at
the bits and bytes in that channel then
we have integrity no one should actually
be able to play around with the bits and
bytes in there and change them without
me or Bob noticing and usually
particularly for message based systems
such as PG gizem as mine we have
non-repudiation which means that I
cannot deny that I said something ok
when Alice sends a message to Bob Bob
can actually prove that
listen only Alice could have sent it
that is a non-repudiation property that
sounds familiar that sounds right as I
said the basis of a lot of the security
technology out there well that makes
sense the secure channel does make sense
but in a very restricted context okay
first we have to assume that we can do
very good key management ok that Alice
and Bob can share key that we have a
public key infrastructure all that stuff
this might be the case in environments
like the military or enterprises there
is no public infrastructure that allows
me to easily deploy my solutions then it
is it's making sense to have
non-repudiation properties as part of
the secure channel if we're doing
business-to-business transactions if our
transactions are quite likely to end up
in court okay it makes sense and we sign
things and we can prove to a judge that
oh she sent me a message saying he's
going to sell me this he never did send
him to jail find him ok but these are
not really the properties that small
entities expect when chatting to each
other ok so if you say to my grandmother
what is a secure channel she's not going
to think well it's a channel in which
it's secured to the business-to-business
transactions she's going to say no like
I had a secure channel my life of being
hushing into people's ears when I wanted
to keep something secret that's the
definition of the secure channel to most
people and really the security of the
security analyst provided today doesn't
really follow this very much there are
two particular aspects that are a bit
off that model IE the model of what you
expect of security when you are talking
to your grandmother in the year or when
you are briefing a journalist talking on
the phone to your lawyer and all these
things the first aspect is that instead
of non-repudiation what you really want
is plausible deniability
which is its opposite plausible
deniability is the ability to deny that
you said something five minutes or the
ability the disability of the other side
to actually prove any statements okay
and this property was first actually
proposed by michael rowe who's the
microsoft lab in cambridge so again it's
someone from microsoft at first did his
PhD thesis on this topic plausible
deniability the second thing you expect
is that because you're a small entity
you don't have much ability to actually
resist compulsion the compulsion that
might actually force you to give you
keys out to read all your communication
so the property you really care about is
forward secrecy you want as soon as you
put down the phone to know that this
will never be recoverable again so you
know that if bob was honest and put down
the phone as well and you put down the
phone too no matter how much did people
torture you or put pressuring you
blackmail you this conversation is gone
and gone forever okay and these key
properties of you know came a bit as a
surprise i have to say when Nikita boris
often in goldberg wrote a paper about
off the record communication and it very
clearly said that these are the
properties that people care about in the
modern word of instant messaging and
voice over IP not non-repudiation not
just confidentiality okay so i have lots
of material to go back to in the context
of the secure channel we could also talk
about anonymity while leak to any third
parties or even the communication
partners your real identity why not just
be pseudonymous then there is more
material and compulsion resistance which
is a variant of forward security as i
mentioned already I the disability of
people to put pressure on you to violate
your security properties and this sounds
really strange maybe and really
contributed but election schemes that
are really important a major part of
computer security research these days
and also a major part of all the
constitutional problems that many
countries have election schemes need
receipt freeness I the inability for you
to sell your vote or under compulsion to
prove that you voted one way or the
other so it's quite mainstream now data
sharing is a hard part because as I said
we have to rely on the ability and I'm
scared to talk about because JC cannon
is a specialist on how to integrate
privacy into the software development
process and thinking about it from
specifications all the way to the
product so I'm scared to talk too much
about it censorship resistance is
another property abuse resistance is
something I can't really give too many
insights because it's it's an infancy so
I'm just going to jump into conclusions
and allow the discussion to develop and
maybe we want to go back to some aspects
if people wonder about them so I hope
that I have convinced you that privacy
instead of being thought in only
sociological or psychological terms is
useful to be thought as a security
property and be studied as a first-class
security citizen ok and when we say that
security is important or microsoft says
security is important these days privacy
has to be considered in that framework
not as something else now that's
something to just deal with privacy
policies and actually if you talk to
many people and you really interview
them you will discover that this
information self-determination is the
most valued thing they have they hate it
when their internet service providers
start blocking them from services they
hate it if they actually know that their
phone is under surveillance and voice
over IP is going to bring all these
issues to the internet they don't like
it and of course as I said security
provides tools to reason about these
things we have security policies threat
models security requirements engineering
cryptography all these things that we
need to mobilize to help privacy not
just let privacy be an architectural
issue so
I guess I should end my formal talk here
if there are any questions it's the time
to ask them but also if people are shy
and do not want to discuss in public
there is a an email here and again if
people want to engage more deeply into
this whole debate and meet the key
people who work in to such research the
privacy enhancing technologies workshop
is the best place to be either when if
you want to present a paper there or if
you just want to hang around and talk to
the people it's very much a workshop
people sit around and talk about these
issues they don't just listen to
presentation finally thanks a lot to JC
can for setting up this whole initiative
and also inviting me here thanks a lot
also to caspar bowden who's been doing
fantastic work in privacy policy in
Europe and the Middle East guess any
questions will this slider be available
for virtue later yes haha it will be
available on the privacy research
website which is available to HR aware
there's a pine tree category it's like a
mess our privacy to get two HR web put
the privacy security area ms our privacy
and then you'll see his face and
there'll be a link to his death on the
right-hand side all right yeah and of
course it when you talked about
anonymous credentials you can talk about
relocation or limiting used to a single
person I mean if the membership is truly
for one person I stopped another person
can carry that card or how do you
prevent someone from using it passes so
that I think is one of the most
challenging aspects of any privacy
technology and this is what i put in the
category of abuse control now abuse
control is not something to be seen as
antithetical to privacy in these
particular case credentials but it's
something to be seen in conjunctions and
in a blur if we're not able to actually
do what you just mentioned then it's
useless because I make one credential
and then everybody is getting into the
cinema or something like that so there
are many ways of doing it one way is to
have just single use credentials like
coins ok you have electronic coins you
can spend them once but if you spend
them a second time the mathematics work
out in such a way that your identity
comes out a key that may be unlock some
kind of you know part of money or some
kind of other mechanism comes out so you
start have some tracing mechanism there
ok that's one way of doing it the second
way of doing it is for people not to be
able to pull credentials together in
such things is to link your credential
showing with something that is really
valuable to you like your bank account
so if you share one credential ie your
ability to get into the movies you're
forced to share everything else so
sharing might still happen between I
don't know husband and wife maybe
because they trust each other to such a
degree that it's okay for them to share
credentials for everything but if I just
come here for a day and you want to let
me into I don't know
your fitness club it's unlikely that
you'll give me my your credentials
because it means that I can also go to
your bank and get your money okay so
these are two ways of doing it then
there is a third one which is the most
controversial in the community which is
full escrow I if I get into a parking
lot and there is a crime that happened
then there might be a third-party
authority that allows to just end mask
everybody who came in even though at the
time it was anonymous and that is very
controversial still and I can talk about
it if you want so I understand the
single user ticketing uses the end
how do i buy the ticket electronically
right now I have to use visa and that's
decidedly not
that's right so and the escrow system is
to go to that well it might be a system
by which you put an arranged to actually
for the hiding of your anonymity I think
we know that no business will take that
liability on against government
intricate so the Patriot Act and it is
today is allowing bookstore records of
vibrate records to be disclosed you know
without any kind of outside knowledge
and so let's not trust such an escrow
potentially that's I guess that is at
the heart of why the escrow debate is
very controversial so we have a right so
let me let me give you one example of
why credential technology might still be
useful in the context for example of
some kind of library you might want the
fact that you register with the library
not to be anonymous the fact that i'm a
member of this library then you get your
credentials but then which books you're
requesting for example to the front desk
to read that you might want to do in an
anonymous way so having the credential
and proving that you're yes i am a
member but i'm not going to tell you
whom when i'm requesting i don't know
how to make nuclear weapons or how to
actually read the communist manifesto i
don't know what could be dodgy depending
i don't want to tell you who I am so
even though at the point of issuing you
might not be anonymous the fact that you
can actually access the service
anonymously might provide still some
kind of confidence the second issue you
bring in actually from a policy point of
view is really crucial that escrow is
really questionable when the full
mechanism that enables the escrow is not
integrated in the security policy right
now we are faced with really simple
minded escrow policies such as
everything works according to our
security and privacy policy but then
there is this magic third party who can
basically compromise the whole thing and
the real question is the following if
there is such a third party that we can
trust to not compromise that the system
why don't we trust them to offer the
security properties to start with okay
and that is a very technical way of
thinking why we should be an easy about
escrow if we really trust this third
party
compromised our security why don't we
just offload facilities to them why
don't we ask them to do our key
management as well why don't we ask them
to actually you know your go and tell
them in clear what you want to say Alice
and to Alice and then they go and tell
Alice what you said you know I mean and
when you start thinking in these very
technical terms you realize that you
still feel uneasy about having a third
party that can magically compromise your
security properties now I'm not a
hundred percent against escrow what I'm
saying is that if the recess crew the
mechanisms that enable it must be
integrated in the security policy both
in terms of auditing in terms of
everything okay and then you discover
that actually law enforcement since you
brought that example it's very cautious
about exposing their internal mechanisms
we're performing the escrow into the
open system and there it's an any easy
situation now because I don't know which
way it's going to go the technology is
there to go both ways so so let's take a
lot a lot of systems that use bedrooms
two is this is today a build with
surveillance in mind such I think like a
lot of information for logging Serena
promise of best best effort keep it
private however it is always at a third
party I can come in review everything at
the state as issues to north early on
you have a slide about non-repudiation
for secrecy or that kind of stuff if
those are the records start then there
will be no need no no concern of the
information we dug up later on
that is true that sadly we have made
choices when it comes to an
infrastructure particularly the mobile
telecommunication infrastructure is a
very good example of exactly what you
mentioned that the choices that were
made very early on we're very much
influenced by of course the needs of the
operators rather than automatically the
needs of the final users and then on the
table of the discussions when the
standards were where the security agents
is very often but not really the
consumer groups or everybody else and
what we're left is we with GSM that I'm
very familiar with we have linked to
link encryption between the handset and
the mobile station on both sides but
actually we have everything transiting
in clear on the backbones and this is
where usually the interception is taking
place and indeed as you mentioned there
is interception by design because all
the telecommunication equipment is
designed to support interception so it's
very difficult to start from a system
like that and try to secure it pretty as
the CODIS
it's right the pressure is that this
system was designed with the following
false assumption in mind gsm it was
designed with the assumption that it's
okay to provide second-rate security to
the users because the users we really
care about ie the military the
government and also enterprises are
going to roll out their own
infrastructures reducing secure
communications the military and has the
know-how to build encrypted phones and
in Greece actually one of the replies
when people were like well the Prime
Minister got bug was oh no no it's okay
that his phone is bugged because he
still has an encrypted phone on his desk
and that doesn't convince anyone today
because we know that the GSM
infrastructure is actually used by
everybody we know that the police in
London when their radios have problems
they found it better to actually pick up
the GSM and call rather than not
communicate and such things so the
pressure to build privacy to start with
is that this is going to secure the
infrastructure and that the Prime
Minister is going to be using that in
same infrastructure that you're using
too so I guess that this is a more
realistic pressure than just say because
it's good for you it's good for the
world or something like that that does
not cover your question or not I feel
that you're dissatisfied
software here at other places where
privacy is important to live an extent
to an extent where we'll try our best
but we still going bought information to
oh la la la ooh I felt there's a bias to
watch surveillance incident was an NHS
privacy I don't know if anything we do
about it I agree there is a bias but I
don't put this bias into conspiracy
theory i think that very often we don't
know how to do abuse control without
collecting a lot of data so things that
hinges on habeas information
like towards that in hearing talk to
mobile earlier that people are going to
want from technology that that provides
some assurances where possible at
procedures and audits where is not where
is it possible to provide assurance what
assurances can you provide that data
system is giving you privacy so okay
Kenneth software itself provide right so
there are two levels I think of
assurances the first level is at the
level of all the standard the interfaces
the communication protocols everything
that is conceptually bridging systems
and parts together if we start actually
thinking about privacy from the ground
up and we start integrating privacy
properties in all the standards the
protocols and all that stuff it is
easier to then go and audit and say okay
this is a correct implementation of a
standard that takes into account privacy
then if no one has thought about this
issue before it has to be retrofitted
after that that's the first level so
this car like doing phipps that's right
i mean how you make standards is a whole
new other thing but at thinking about
privacy when making standard is quite
important and it's something that only
very recently has been done it's it's a
it happens these days but it's a very
new trend in comparison with a history
of the internet the second thing is to
build systems that are more friendly
towards generally auditing for any
property what server and some properties
will be privacy properties I mobilizing
a full arsenal of software engineering
techniques that allow us to say
something about software is it correct
does it provide the properties we care
about when I put my name on this side am
I sure that it's not going up in the
marketing department it's only going to
end up in the I don't know shipping
department building software like that
is hard okay I'm sure that people here
have way more experience than I do in
doing it building software that provides
assurances is hard but so far very few
people have thought about providing
assurances visibly privacy
and if that changes maybe we're going to
step towards having more privacy
friendly information environments so
these are the two things I'm thinking of
a couple of things buy more of a privacy
guy than a security guy so this is this
been fascinating because it's kind of
turning things on their head a little
bit because most privacy people use
security is a property of privacy
hopefully when you go back to the OECD
guidelines in 25 years ago where you go
to any privacy of data protection law
around the world or any privacy policy
than an organization communicates you'll
see that security is a component right
and keep requirement now I assume that
your scope is slightly different because
you're talking about systems and things
but I you know if you've got any
comments on that of the interest yes
absolutely I think that part of the kind
of misalignment of the two words is the
fact that security is used to mean
different things right so in my word
security is the set of techniques we
have a set of mechanisms in the sense of
mindsets that we have in order to make
sure that systems perform as we wish
them to perform when there is
adversarial behavior when other people
would wish them to work differently it's
a very general definition and then we
have security mechanisms such as
encryption secure channels things like
that that I think is what in the context
of data protection security is meant i
ii when in data protection people say
that the data must be kept securely they
mean that it must somehow be encrypted
or there should be some authentication
of who can access it they're really
thinking of a set of mechanisms but what
I'm talking about is kind of one level
lap I guess I about the policies the
properties and then the mechanisms are
going to be there to address these
properties that are desirable and be
able to implement them in real software
and real algorithms real mathematics or
not so I guess that the misalignment is
it's not as deep i think as both
security and privacy communities think
no no i actually think your line is
becoming tighter yeah and from a couple
of things one some we did some research
last summer with consumers and IT
professionals to key audiences for our
company in and one of the things we did
was explore the relationship between
privacy and security in their minds
the consumers space they use the word
going to change
and but they really positioned privacy
as one of the key outcomes of security
and when we specifically asked them what
actions they took to protect their
privacy it was security technologies
that they were talking about right
firewalls and antivirus so I mean these
two things they finally mesh together
and one definition of privacy which I
don't think i saw you present you know
you talked about freedom from
surveillance and being watched you
talked about this notion of control
which is something we strongly adopt as
a key definitional element here but
another is protection from heart of
misuse of your information and that's
right things like identity theft come
into play and you know that's clearly
where security and privacy come together
a lot and I think that's what was behind
that consumers reactions when they
talked about security technologies to be
honest I have one slide about issues of
data sharing but I'm on purpose shy
about this because I don't have very
good answers it's it's a very hard
problem it's a hard problem to make
distributed systems work at all let
alone provide any correctness properties
let alone then provide any security
properties for any parties let alone
provide multilateral security properties
I security for the consumer and the shop
so it's it's already so up the
difficulty level that at least in
academia people prefer to look at very
specific mechanisms very small scale
systems which probably doesn't help you
guys much but maybe in a bit we'll be
able to reason about more complex
systems that's why I left it out not
because it's not important it is the
most important